foreign
[Music]
22 a show from The Spectator where we
look at something a little bit different
my name is Freddie gray I am the
deputyator of The Spectator and this
week we're going to be talking about
succession the brilliant I think I think
it's an undeniably brilliant TV series
that has ended this week
I'm joined by Andrew Neal who is the
chairman of The Spectator a big
succession fan and something of an
expert on the Murdoch family and I
should warn anyone watching uh that has
not watched the series and intends to
watch the series that there will be
spoilers and that includes the
spectators editor Fraser Nelson who's
been saving up succession for a binge at
some point when we give him some free
time so Fraser Look Away now and anyone
in Fraser's position should look away
now
Andrew uh succession is now over and we
are going to give away some spoilers so
uh could you please tell me what you
thought about the ending it's
notoriously difficult to end these
series these great epic finale's
um when nobody wants it to end did you
think they did it very well
this is a huge test for these big budget
uh very up Market
with huge production values American
series is the ending
um until now until succession Breaking
Bad had probably the most satisfactory
ending of all that was the way to do it
Game of Thrones was the way not to do it
again another massive budget beautiful
production values great storytelling but
it really screwed up the end succession
did not indeed I think of anything it
exceeded expectations of just how good
the ending would be and as we know from
Game of Thrones if you get the ending
wrong uh people remember that and they
forget all the other good stuff that
came before succession did not do that
it ended on a high a great High I think
a dramatic uh high and it didn't tie up
every loose end but that's not the job
of a program like that there are too
many Loose Ends but it did answer some
major questions of which the fundamental
conclusion it came to is was that none
of the three siblings In Contention were
up to doing the job and so a media
Empire the Logan Roy had spent his life
building ended up in the hands of a
Swedish Tech entrepreneur
which leads me on to what I I want to
ask you about most of all which is uh
the similarity of uh the story of the
Roy family
uh this media uh Empire family and the
murdochs
um and obviously they are based the the
boys are based on the murdochs
um you know the Murdoch family to what
extent
did they capture the Murdoch's
accurately
well I think the the overlap with the
murder uh Dynasty or as our American
cousins would say Dynasty the overlap
with with that was very clever because
there was enough of an overlap to make
it interesting and enough of a noble lap
to say yeah that's happened in real life
that's the kind of thing that goes on
but not enough to give the lawyers at
HBO palpitations
not not enough to wonder worry that
there would be massive lawsuits coming
in and the three siblings in succession
and Mr Murdock's three they're siblings
of James Lachlan and uh and Elizabeth
again two two men one woman they had a
few similarities but frankly none of
them uh was like the character that they
uh said
however
there were some fundamental uh of things
that were very similar to real life
first of all the way Logan Roy by the
way the the name Roy was chosen as close
to French Hua for King so the way Logan
King ran his company was like a king uh
you know he didn't run it like a CEO or
a chairman or anything like that he ran
it like a king and all the executives
around him were courteous that's exactly
how Rupert Murdock has run his company
in my book many years ago now full
disclosure I had a chapter called the
Sun at the court of the Sun King because
Murdoch behaved like the Sun King it
wasn't a hierarchical pyramid structure
of the company it was the king of the
middle and the courtiers all the way
round so I think they got that right
they also got something else right too
in the just as in succession
in the end the Empire goes uh the the
Logan Roy family doesn't get it in a
sense a lot of that's already happened
with the murder Corporation you know I
watched them sometimes quite in close
quarters uh by the television stations
in America uh by 20 20th Century Fox in
America built up a fourth U.S Network
and make major blockbuster movies uh out
in Los Angeles and so on while still
having his newspapers uh both in
Australia in Australia and Britain and
of course in the United States as well
but a huge chunk of that is now gone
just as the whole of the Logan
Roy Empire went you know the 20th
Century Fox has gone to Disney a lot of
the television production has gone to
Disney as well and basically there is
only a rump left in the Murdoch
organization now it's a pretty big
problem by anybody else's standards but
by Mr Murdoch standards it's not that
big it's the British papers the Sun the
times the Sunday Times other small TV
radio assets they're really de Minimus
it is the Wall Street Journal in America
above all its boss news that is is what
Richard Nixon would call the big
enchilada uh that's the one that
generates all the money is the one that
I understand takes up most of his time
now but it's a shadow of what was there
before and just as you saw in succession
the Empire basically disappearing with
the demise of Logan Royal
because I think he in his heart too you
remember that Betty says early on in
series four you are not serious people
for I love you but you are not serious
people I think that spoke to everything
about Logan Roy they were only Rich
because he made them Rich they'd never
earned a penny in their lives on their
own under their own steam I think in a
way when Rupa murder goes to the great
Newsroom in the Sky What's Left of the
Murdoch Empire is already gone none of
the siblings is interested in running
British newspapers they're not really
interested in the Wall Street Journal
either James and Elizabeth are
embarrassed by Fox News they'll want rid
of that as well so I think you already
begin to see the demise in the Empire
the way you did in succession so that's
where real life and uh drama fiction I
do think come together that point about
empires in Decline and a lot of great
literature uh you know you think about
Chekhov or in the 20th century evening
War uh is about things as they're
collapsing uh so with the aristocracy or
whatever
and I think that's what I I think the
appeal of succession is it's almost a
bit of nostalgia about something that
still exists but is in precipitous
Decline and do you think that's what it
is that there's this sort of great
attraction to what we want to be
powerful in a way because we're used to
it being powerful and yet in the new
digital world it isn't
it has been about the building up of an
Empire and I think both in real life
with the Murdoch Empire and with the
Logan Roy Empire in succession it's also
about how you spend your whole life
building up an Empire like that and when
you've done it
it's actually passed its sell by date uh
that it's huge it dominates it's massive
but the world has moved on because we
live in market economies Tech is a huge
disrupter and everything that seemed
Cutting Edge owning television stations
24-hour news channels awning movie
stations streaming
takes them apart you know theme park
multi-channel TV takes it apart and then
it's quite hard to come up to stay ahead
of that kind of technical change now the
the thing that Bo I think is in in many
ways to the credit of Rupert Murdock and
to Logan Roy I'm treating them both now
as real people
is that he both recognized that
they didn't try to hang on to their
Empires that had been their life's work
and and then pass them on to the kids
who they didn't think were worth it in
the end they basically broke up their
Empires they realized life had changed
so Rupert Murdoch sends sells a huge
chunk of his Empire to Disney because he
doesn't think big as he is he has the
size to compete with the screaming
giants like Netflix and Amazon Prime and
so on and let's not forget in succession
it's not the kids that wanted to sell to
a Swedish Tech entrepreneur and a narco
capitalist it was Logan Roy that did
that it was Logan Roy that started the
sale uh to Madison uh of Sweden he too
like Rupa murder could recognize
actually it's basically over now I've
been overtaken by events so let's just
get the money out and enjoy myself and
maybe dabble in something else I think
that's you know most Empires end up
crumbling and going wrong and have a
messy ending because those who created
them try to hold on to them that is a
history of Empires throughout the world
did even only the the British Empire
doesn't actually fit too much into that
we did pretty much good remember unlike
France we didn't have an Algeria we
didn't have a Vietnam or anything like
it indeed most of the violence started
after we got out as in India or parts of
Africa and I think it was interesting
that they cranky unpleasant rude and all
the rest of it uh authoritarian that
they were they recognized it was time to
move on that if you try to hold on to an
Empire whose cell by date is over it's
messy let us have a clean ending which
again I thought showed a depth of
understanding in succession of what
happened and is still happening in real
life with the Murdoch operation
similar are the Murdoch children to the
Roy children I mean obviously the Logan
and Logan Roy the patriarch and Rupert
Murdoch there are similarities but the
Rupert Murdoch's Australian and a bit
different looking and a slightly
different atmosphere about well they've
got something quite common with River
Murdock you know don't forget Rupert
murders family Hills from the east of
Scotland and Logan Roy hailed from the
east of Scotland a little bit further
south he hailed from Dundee River
Murdock's family came from Aberdeen but
Logan Ryan was first generation whereas
Rupa Murdoch is third generation
Australian and actually pretty close to
Australia Australian aristocracy as you
can get we've don't fall for the Wild
Colonial boy outside in nonsense and he
spoke to spoke to Rupert's mum you would
realize just how aristocratic that in a
country without aristocrats the murder
Corporation was as close as you can get
his father had a Knighthood as well it
was a real part of the Australian
establishment he went to Geelong grammar
which is where Prince Charles went
whereas Logan Roy in succession is the
poor kid uh entirely self-made sent to
America during the second world war to
escape the bombing and the Nets he's in
all the rest of it so there were the
similarities but also differences as for
the children individually if you take uh
uh Siobhan to be Elizabeth uh
um James I think to be well I'm not
quite sure James to be Roman no James to
be candle me because he's a bit more
liberal and Lachlan to be a candle
that aren't really that many many
similarities uh between them uh they're
very different and whereas Siobhan in
the series has really no Senior
Management experience Elizabeth Murdock
went her own way and created a pretty
successful television production company
so she kind of did her own thing because
it always helps to have your father in
the background and so on but even so you
know knowing jokes like Roman or as a
term of phrase they're quite both James
and um Lachlan are quite taciturn
I would say that they do have one thing
in common
in that is that just as in succession so
in real life none of them has or had the
ability to run the Murdoch organization
when it was in full flourish they just
weren't up to it as they weren't in the
TV series either
and is there another similarity in that
for their whole lives
um this is what Logan Roy does with the
Roy children
the prospect of being the big boss is is
dangled in front of them as a carrot
yes I saw it firsthand when uh James uh
and uh Lachlan were basically in their
mid-teens how he he did dangle this in
front of him did I remember having
dinner in London one Saturday night
after I put the Sunday Times to bed and
they both turned up and he did kind of
dangle you know one day you will run
this and I want to make sure you can do
that and you'll have to do this you'll
have to learn this and all the rest of
it so yes he did do that and he kind of
set them against each other as well
and for a long while Elizabeth because
she was female was never included in
that I mean he didn't really think women
could do that sort of thing I think over
time he may have changed his mind and of
course Siobhan and shiv has that
wonderful phrase he couldn't get a whole
woman in his head uh in the final
episode or in the second in the
penultimate episode of the funeral uh
oration and I think for a long while
that was true of Rupa Murdoch too I
think he may have changed uh uh that but
yes he set them against each other he
always I mean I used to tease him I used
to say you don't like the Royal Family
do you no not really
um you don't like him because it's
hereditary yep that's exactly right
um what's the difference between that
and a murder Dynasty wouldn't that be
hereditary as well and he said oh shut
up you know what I mean shut up we move
on to something else uh there so that
was always something a little bit
different he always had and he tried out
various people you know at one stage
James was um the front runner uh now
Lachlan is the front runner from what's
left so he's based in Sydney these days
I don't know you run America from the
other side of the Pacific it was kind of
suggested that Liz might like to throw
her he you know her
uh lock in to see if she could get it
but I don't think that really attracted
her very very much so to that extent yes
what I would say over one thing the
succession did not get and was deeply
missing was that in succession
uh the kid's mother
the slightly aristocratic English woman
is Holy useless uh and a bad mother and
wholly useless as an individual I think
as well that is not true of the real
life mother when Rupert was Conquering
the world these three kids as they were
at the time were very lucky to have Anna
Murdoch as a mother for 30 years married
to Rupert and she did a really good job
the kids were always no matter how rich
they were or even how entitled they felt
in my dealings with them they were
unfailingly polite and not at all
obnoxious the way I have seen rich kids
can be the mother did a great job on
that
well it's interesting you touched on the
children's politics there in in the
series
and obviously there's been a lot of
writing talk about the similarity
between ATN and Fox News and for me I
felt that was where and we've had a
couple of pieces have said similar
things on on The Spectators website
that's where it started crypto series
started creeping towards political
lecturing
uh about that there was the election
episode in the final series uh where you
got the real sense of the political
views of the writers and what was great
about it most of the time was everything
was ambiguous uh and it was you the
viewer allowed to think
um did you feel that it got a little bit
too political at times I was worried
that it was going to protect
particularly I think what was a decision
night or whatever the name of the
episode was which was the overnight
there is you know having done the BBC's
live election coverage I loved that
because it was just it really got things
pretty right uh in terms of the
excitement of all the results coming in
and so on and I think there was a danger
I mean you can be pretty sure that
everybody behind the scenes involved in
this program is on the left I don't
think there's any doubt about that and
the the ATM they created they saw as Fox
News which naturally they would hate and
I thought there was a danger in one
stage that they were going to go down
the road in which here you have this
huge media Mogul whose television
station alone was going to determine the
outcome of the result
and of course that didn't happen in real
life and the the in the end I think they
put I think Freddie they pulled back
just in time
because of course in reality far from
Fox News on the night in 2020 calling it
for Donald Trump they called Arizona for
Joe Biden they did the exact opposite of
what happened in the succession show
where they called Wisconsin for the hard
right character even though a lot of the
ballots had been burnt and so on so I
think I think they may have gone over
Jesse Armstrong who I don't know but I'm
told is very Savvy he's the British
showrunner the British main screenwriter
with the whole thing I think he must
have realized hold on we're in danger of
the one thing we've not done is lecture
people or give walk sentiments we've let
people make up their minds so let's
maybe just pull back a little bit from
this so we don't go down that road it
was on the brink but I think it pulled
back in time and also uh Menken the the
right-wing populist man on the verge of
being elected president as the series
ends is not actually that similar to
Donald Trump he's much canier and and
more Sly I would say much more civilized
yeah
and and the way he watches as the as all
the not just the Logan rise siblings and
those associated with them but other
people come up to them and the way even
Madison the Swedish entrepreneur comes
up and he's very controlled and very of
that wonderful uh line I've not got the
quote exactly right but he says the
candle Oh I thought you were just a
sound system but now you want to choose
the playlist
I mean that was brilliant I mean that's
a brilliant quote yeah that is a
Shakespearean use of the language is
just wonderful and I don't actually see
why they I thought it was a little bit
stupid that they met him out to be more
right-wing than he needed to be for the
character to work because at one stage
they're kind of almost implying he's
just one step away from Hitler you don't
have to go anywhere that far you just
have to be kind of trumpian to be able
to get the point across so I think when
they dabbled in politics sometimes that
was the show looked in danger of taking
a wrong turn but it looks to me my new
one disciplined enough to avoid that and
it was I thought it was interesting
Freddie the way they portrayed the right
way in Canada because as you say they
didn't portray him as a complete Nutter
an idea login they they portrayed him as
actually a rather serious calculating
politician and finally Andrew this is
the vital question uh I know that you
have succession as your ringtone because
I've heard it
I want to ask now that the series is
over how long will it continue to be
your telephone ringtone
well on my French mobile I've got House
of Cards the American version theme tune
and that finished a long time ago and
hasn't come back so I think you can take
it the succession will remain my
ringtone for a long long while perhaps
for the foreseeable future my British
mobile because uh it brings back such
happy memories it won't move on to the
to be the French ringtone
uh no I use my British one more so I get
to hear that more and people that you
call me on my British one as well so I
get to hear it more and I love that and
it will bring back nothing but happy
memories of a great television series in
which the British
Talent played a huge part both in front
of the camera and behind the camera but
when you see something like succession
or Breaking Bad before please don't tell
me anymore the British TV is the best in
the world it's not American TV using
British talent where it needs it is the
best in the world
[Music]
thank you
foreign